good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 2,700 object
class safe special containment
procedures SCP 2,700 is held at secure
bunker only personnel with for 2,700
clearance are permitted to access the
bunker SCP 2,700 is contained in a ten
by five by ten meter concrete vault and
is not to be transported or tampered
with under any circumstances description
SCP 2,700 is a complex mechanical device
believed to be a sophisticated
directed-energy weapon developed by
serbian physicist and inventor Nikola
Tesla the device was discovered in 1946
and recovered from a defunct but heavily
secured research facility utilized by
Tesla in during 1934 SCP 2,700 consists
of three components the interface SCP
2701 the accelerator SCP 2702 and the
core SCP 2703
SCP 2701 is a steel control console
featuring a QWERTY keyboard 23 by 23
centimeter display screen and a number
of buttons switches and levers SCP 2701
is connected to SCP 2702 and SCP 2703 by
a network of copper wiring the display
screen features a command based
operating system with commands and
responses appearing in green block text
the nature of SCP 27-hundred ones
operating system is still under
investigation
SCP 2702 is believed to be a linear
particle accelerator held in a
lead-lined tungsten cylindrical chamber
the device contains all the components
that would be required for a
contemporary particle accelerator though
it is significantly smaller 7.35 metres
in length than a device of this design
would require please see document SCP
2702 for full information on the
individual components of the accelerator
SCP 2703 identified as the core in
Tesla's schematics is a lead-lined
tungsten assembly containing an
apparatus of currently unclear function
this apparatus which is observable via a
silicate glass viewport consists of a
spherical frame constructed of an
unidentified substance this frame is
approximately 10 centimeters in diameter
and is suspended with a transparent
sphere the composition of which also
remains unidentified
according to Tesla's notes the space
within this sphere is held in a
perpetual vacuum state present within
the frame as a continuous current of
plasma generated and perpetuated by
unknown means available information
suggests that particles produced in SCP
2703 would then be introduced into SCP
2702 and accelerated as expected for
such a device energetic particles would
then be propelled from the terminus of
SCP 2702 toward the intended target how
the device is powered and the exact
nature of the particles produced by SCP
2703 remains unclear
attention clearance level for 2,700
personnel the fact that you are able to
read this text verifies your security
clearance and access to the following
documentation please continue bound to
document scp-2000 700 PE personnel under
level 4 may be granted emergency access
to this document through provision Omega
our file item number SCP 2,700 object
class
Keter special containment procedures the
above falsified document is to be made
available for all personnel without for
2,700 clearance SCP 27 hundreds
containment vault is located 180 meters
from the surface level entrance to
secure bunker the vault itself is to be
insulated against seismic activity and
safeguarded by three sets of reinforced
steel doors access to the vault is
forbidden
barring semi hourly inspection unless
there is a risk of imminent containment
failure and contingency procedures are
necessary all personnel entering the
vault are to be equipped with betray
coat auxin collars which are to be
activated for any breach of protocol SCP
2,700 is to remain under constant
surveillance and all data regarding the
state of SCP 2,700 Omega is to be
updated semi hourly personnel tasked
with assessing a CP 2,700 one's
operating system must adhere to a set of
guidelines present in document SCP 2701
there is to be no direct interaction
with a CP 2703
barring unanimous approval of the l5
Council breaches of this protocol
warrant immediate termination any change
in the behavior of SCP 2,700 Omega must
be reported immediately as such activity
could result in a YK class event
personnel assigned to the containment of
SCP 2,700 are to investigate all
available material related to the origin
and function of SCP 2,700 the primary
objective in regards to the artifacts
containment is to be its deactivation
prior to the occurrence of a YK class
event in light of the catastrophic
severity a possible breach by a CP 2,700
presents statute 30 a may be waived by
personnel with five 2,700 clearance
proposals for the cross neutralization
of SCP 2,700 utilizing other SCP objects
including those of Kenner class may be
presented to the o-5 Council for
evaluation in the event of imminent
containment failure SCP 2703
is to be disposed on via the currently
approved cross neutralization SCP object
description SCP 2,700 is a device
originally constructed by Nikola Tesla
with the purpose of producing a
directed-energy weapon investigation of
the artifact while in foundation custody
however has proven that SCP 2,700
possesses a function distinct from and
significantly more dangerous than its
original designs SCP 2701
and SCP 2702 are as described in the
above document however SCP 2703 is not
the luminescent anomaly located in the
center of SCP 2703 is not plasma as
previously indicated but a discrete
energy phenomenon now designated SCP
2,700 Omega SCP 2,700 Omega behaves
inversely with regards to entropy the
energy state within its boundaries
constantly moves from thermal
equilibrium to thermal singularity from
disorganised to organized in other words
the flow of energy moves from the state
of maximum entropy to minimal entropy
which is opposite to the standard for
the rest of the universe due to this the
effective flow of time within this
region is also reversed presently the
unidentified materials surrounding the
region the frame and transparent sphere
are immune to the effects of SCP 2,700
Omega this appears to be the only factor
preventing a breach of the phenomenon if
SCP 2,700 Omega were to escape the
interior of SCP 2703 and an x-ray oval
chain reaction would occur converting
the rest of the universe to this
inverted and tropics state the
eventualities of this scenario would be
a YK class and tropic annihilation event
resulting in the reduction of the entire
universe to an infinitely energetic
singularity ostensibly an inverted Big
Bang
as indicated by a CP 2701
the device is currently armed and set to
activate in 2234 exactly 300 years after
its initial arming and this would
inherently trigger a breach of a CP
2,700 Omega current containment
protocols must be completed prior to the
set date to avert a YK class event
addendum 2701
the following is an excerpt from
personal log written by Tesla in 1934 it
stands before me complete and
inescapably counting down toward the
Nexus of my oversights
and failures only one month ago I was
approached by a man I had never seen
before he was the most content person I
had ever seen his eyes felt like a
window into serenity he said he was
looking for the most curious mind in the
world and I was it apparently I wasn't
hard to distinguish from the billions of
other minds on the planet not that it
surprises me somehow I knew immediately
that he wasn't from here and I felt
self-conscious about this world my world
it felt humiliating to me I think he
knew what I was feeling during those
brief windows when I was not isolated in
my work I would glimpse these events
unfolding elsewhere I never cared for
what I saw the world is too broke to
feed itself and it's responding like a
hungry animal it's angry war is coming I
can only hope that in the conflict
nature will take its course and the
lingering degenerates of our species are
expunged it's because of the degenerates
at war erupts that more is the only
thing that can clean them from
civilization
that is the way of any system when the
unnecessary pieces build-up to critical
mass chaos brings the destruction that
returns things to equilibrium but his
smile just seemed to cut right through
the Maelstrom of disgust then inadequacy
in my head
then came the truth he was looking for
the most ingenious Minds from each of
the other universes
he found my lack of astonishment to the
phrase other universes surprising I
asked how many there were and he said he
did not know in addition to his own in
mine they had only found five others
that were coherent and could support
life if anything I was astonished that
there were only seven found he laughed
at that said I seemed promising to him I
asked him what he wanted me for to
unlock Sciences final secret we prepared
for departure over the next 24 hours I
asked the traveler if I could take my
project with me and have his people look
at it to which he replied that it would
be no problem the teleforce had hid
substantial roadblocks I had no way to
develop a power source sufficient for it
I didn't tell him what it was I just
said it was an accelerator not a weapon
I didn't want him second-guessing my
motivations I thought that if I could
complete it in his universe I could
bring it back and take care of the
equilibrium problem myself we left early
in the morning I admit while the
prospect of another universe then
shocked me considerably the premise of
actually travelling there was intriguing
the traveler grabbed my arm and adjusted
something attached to his wrist it
resembled a simple watch but I couldn't
get a good look at it
there was an intense flash and
everything went black
for an instant I thought I'd been
blinded then I felt the terrifying
freefall tumbling through infinite
darkness at unfathomable speed I had
never been more frightened in all my
life even so I experienced wonder and
anticipation such that I had never known
then in an instant it all stopped I
opened my eyes and saw words fail to do
it justice more accurately our words
failed to do with justice just as I
cannot write the travelers true name in
these letters and be satisfied with it I
cannot describe the transcendent beauty
of his home world it was a world with a
pulse a life that I could palpate and at
that point I felt the enormity of my
world's hollow and primitive nature
collapse upon me I cried not at his
world's beauty but at my world's sheer
inferiority I'm relieved that he never
realized the real reason behind those
tears I was brought to a city again I'm
using the word city as nothing more than
the most appropriate analogue there the
traveller introduced me to his family
and to many of his people that feeling
of contentment that he gave me during
our first encounter now surrounded me on
all sides my sense of shame only
deepened this world wasn't just better
it was the closest thing to perfection
that I could possibly imagine
they weren't pointlessly cheery but they
would not tolerate any of the idiotic
and trivial nonsense that people fret
over here
then I met the others one from each
universe as the traveler explained to me
him being the representative of his own
universe I will not go into details on
their appearances this is irrelevant and
ephemeral information that reveals
nothing of their vast intellect and
ingenuity I spent at least a day simply
talking with them I kept my pocket watch
with me during my visit it was the only
thing that kept record of the Earth's
time while I was there they have their
own form of time of course but it was
more practical for me to keep using ours
I vastly enjoyed the time I spent
conversing with them we spoke of things
that I would never dare references
science here but they thought of it as
no more strange than gravity itself the
traveler told everyone what the great
project he had assembled for us once we
were to build a perpetual energy
generator not only that this instill in
me appropriately infinite fascination
but I identified that this was just what
the teleforce needed naturally I
volunteered my device to them to be the
test subject for the generator once it
was finished just to see if it worked to
my delight they accepted this proposal
and we got to work over the course of a
few short weeks we compiled our data and
at last it was I that found the solution
the properties of two specific
substances each from a different
universe when an interaction should
produce the reaction that would catalyze
infinite energy both samples had been
taken from universes that were
inhospitable to our form of life their
subatomic nature was not only at odds
with the realm in which I was residing
but with each other it was only by
virtue of a casual membrane the others
provided me with that the samples could
remain in existence here I was certain
that this paradoxical interaction was
the key
I pored over the notes for nights trying
to finalize the designs it was at that
time that one of the others came to me
offerings help The Watcher is what I
like to call him that's what he did he
watched me all the time I don't know why
and he claimed I was just interested
certainly disconcerting but I could
admit to having the same feeling myself
often he peered over my notes and
pointed out something I had missed a
simple error I had overlooked with that
my calculations were complete and we
were ready to begin the test I was
ecstatic the day came and the traveler
and I loaded the core into the teleforce
for our first initial test at first
everything was going as we had foreseen
but when we inspected at one hour later
one of the others noticed something
unusual the amount of energy inside the
core seemed to be diminishing which
didn't make any sense at all then the
horrific realization came it wasn't
diminishing the energy was converging
upon itself infinitely the core was
reversing the flow of entropy none of
the others failed to see the critical
danger of this predicament if we could
not neutralize the reaction it could
disrupt the flow of entropy for the
entire universe it would reverse time to
the birth of existence hastily I
accessed the console of the teleforce
and saw that someone had set it to
activate in three hundred years I tried
to disable it but I could not the system
would not recognize my commands which
can only mean that someone sabotage the
console then it clicked in my head with
absolute certainty
I spun to face the watcher and declared
him the culprit of the situation he gave
a smile that seemed to contain more
malice than any one being should be
capable of he denied nothing and went
further
he explained that only he knew how to
deactivate the teleforce and that
disassembling it would do nothing but
spread the reaction sooner he leered at
me in that way he always had and I
cursed myself for not figuring it out
sooner some greatest mind I was then he
said it what right did I have to hold
him with contempt when I too came here
to complete a weapon clearly those
wretched eyes had found my journal for
he then begun to describe the teleforce
'as function and purpose he commended me
for coming to another universe to build
it
rather than risk building it in my own
as I was exactly what he did why did he
set it to 300 years it was merely a
safeguard to ensure it didn't activate
while he was still there the watcher
then disappeared back to his own
universe taking the only device capable
of reaching it with him we were left
there with my great invention now a time
bomb for this universe that I grown so
fond of why did The Watcher want to
create such a weapon in the first place
I don't know or care anymore all I cared
about was the fear and hopelessness of
the traveller his family and his world
it was my theories that brought this
upon it was my fault the traveler though
did not blame me and I think that was
the final sign that I had to do what I
did
I took the teleforce back here I took
the death of existence back to my
universe where it belonged I have
betrayed all life-forms in this cosmos I
have betrayed our entire future I am NOT
sorry and I am not apologizing I could
not let my legacy be the destruction of
a universe I was not even worthy of it
seems I will in the end bring the
equilibrium I desire and it will be the
end of our degenerate universe the
teleforce is locked away safely
I spend my long hours before the pond
with the birds they are so blissfully
unaware of what approaches and that
gives me just enough tranquility to
tolerate my own existence a reversal of
energy of entropy of time if reversing
time was a simpler task perhaps I could
have stopped this from ever happening
and save our universe no I wouldn't have
I would have made our universe one worth
saving
[Music]
okay I think that about does it for
today thank you all for listening if
indeed you still are and you are all
dismissed
goodbye I would like to give a special
thank you to researcher Brandon Connell
Burlington the cop slump god
Justin day Pierce M Hamlin white crew
beware 600 Bryson Billy my archive
theater Nick Tiger ball Judi Dench
cheese whip the Android the
administrator quartz 5 6 3 and tree hero
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos on some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the Volgin
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]